that is the Berlin conquered America as
the Dancing with the Stars champion but
how much has her life changed since then
well she went back home to Australia
where she found a new love of her life
I'm talking about this adorable pug
puppy named Stella don't worry everybody
the guy we saw her dating during Dancing
well they are still going strong we had
a quick stuff over to visit tambour and
it was really fun take a hike okay I'm
so funny he was a part of the family now
I'm not sure who loves him more me or my
family Roberts always stealing him away
going to my older brother we're gonna go
play run around so that's great I mean
it's fantastic I mean he's such a kind
and genuine person that I'm really
really blessed
so with that pretty grown up statement
and these adorable make-out photos on
the beach we had to ask bindi could
Chandler be the one he's a huge part of
my journey in life at this point in my
life I am I'm looking forward to a lot
of things I'm gonna be 18 there's so
much on the horizon now that is one very
well worded answer for someone who
doesn't even turn 18 until July
that is so bindi I mean she kind of puts
us all to shame with how mature she is
certainly 18 would be really fun I think
that I'm gonna be celebrating in a very
wild way with cups of tea and maybe some
takeout Chinese food if I'm lucky I'm
gonna ask mom if we can go rent a movie
it'll be a really good night I might
even have two cups of tea just to be
wild right now bindis returned to
working at the Australia Zoo she still
talks to her dancing partner Derek Hough
often but what does the reigning champ
have to say to the new contestants when
I first arrived Dancing with the Stars
they were spray-tanning me and I felt
like a car big painted a different color
and sticking things to my eyelashes
which I now know of false eyelashes
that's interesting I had no clue of
course the reason bindi so down-to-earth
is because of her close bonds with her
family
the legacy left by her father we showed
her video from our et vault and nearly
10 years after Steve Irwin's tragic
death this man is still teaching his
little girl and us all lost what you
make of it Mike you gotta you gotta have
fun you can't waste one minute um being
sad or angry you gonna try and yeah have
fun have fun haven't seen that before
that's really sweet
oh wow bottle yeah I reckon you are
you're a little beauty oh that's so
funny oh how wonderful
that's amazing cuz I still say that when
I grow up I wanna be just like my dad
after losing him it was quite a journey
to try and find that happiness again his
life is sure you have to do what you
love now and you have to do what just
brings you the most joy and dad was the
best at that bindi you are doing
fantastic things and your father would
be so proud no doubt